>> Greg: HAPPY THURSDAY,
EVERYONE -- CONTROL YOURSELVES.
BEFORE WE GET TO THE NEWS, LET'S
CONTINUE OUR HALLOWEEN WEEK WITH
EPISODE 3 OF OUR FAVORITE
SITCOM.
♪ ♪
>> TONIGHT'S EPISODE, A KILLER
COMMUTE.
♪ ♪
[SCREAMING]
>> THEN THEY TOLD ME IT WAS A
2246 -- WOULD YOU LOOK AT THIS?
I'VE SEEN IT A MILLION TIMES.
ANOTHER MINIATURE RED PLASTIC
CAR RUNNING OVER A COWORKER
AFTER BEING DRIVEN RECKLESSLY BY
A TINY GREG GUTFELD DUMMY.
IT NEVER GETS ANY EASIER.
WHAT A WASTE OF TAPE.
>> Greg: IT'S THE ONLY WAY TO
SILENCE EMILY COMPAGNO.
BACK TO THE NEWS AND AS ALWAYS
WHEN IT COMES TO THE NEWS.
EVERYTHING IS RACIST!
THAT'S RIGHT, EVERYTHING IS
RACIST, FOOD, JOKES, VACCINES,
PIGEONS, THAT WEIRD FEELING YOU
GET WHEN YOU INSERT YOUR FINGER
INTO YOUR BELLY BUTTON.
THEN IT TURNS OUT IT'S NOT YOUR
BELLY BUTTON OR ANYONE ELSE'S --
THE ONLY THING THAT'S NOT RACIST
ARE ACTUAL RACISTS.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT A DOCENT IS?
I HAD NO IDEA UNTIL NOW.
IT'S A TERM THAT DESCRIBES
VOLUNTEER GUIDES AT MUSEUMS,
THEY ARE USUALLY OLDER WHITE
LADIES WHO WALK AROUND NOT TELLG
YOU NOT TO TOUCH THE SCULPTURES.
WHY GO TO THE MARKET IF YOU
CAN'T SQUEEZE THE FRUIT, RIGHT?
SOME OF THESE DOCENTS ARE ACTUAL
DONORS TO THE MUSEUM AND I BET
YOUR TYPICAL LIBERALS, JUST
BECAUSE YOU DON'T SEE MANY
DALE EARNHARDT SHIRTS AT THE
MUSEUM OF NATURAL HISTORY.
AT THE ART INSTITUTE OF CHICAGO
MORE THAN 100 DOCENTS WERE FIRED
BECAUSE THEY WEREN'T
SUFFICIENTLY DIVERSE.
VOLUNTEERS WERE FIRED BECAUSE
THEY WERE TOO WHITE AND THAT'S
GOT TO HURT, BEING FIRED AS A
VOLUNTEER COME YOU CAN'T EVEN
COLLECT UNEMPLOYMENT.
IN YOUR FACE, WHITE PRIVILEGE.
I'M ALL FOR IT, I CAN'T TELL YOU
HOW MANY TIMES I THOUGHT I NEED
A MUSEUM TOUR GUIDE WHO LOOKS
JUST LIKE ME.
I REALLY FEEL MARGINALIZED.
WHERE ARE THEY?
IT'S A STRUGGLE FOR ME.
HERE'S ANOTHER EXAMPLE IN WHICH
BOZOS ADOPT THE RHETORIC OF
INCLUSION TO EXCLUDE OTHERS.
THESE ARE EXPERIENCED, PEOPLE
WHO DONATED TIME AND MONEY TO
EDUCATE THE PUBLIC AND THEY WILL
BE HARD TO REPLACE.
AND WHY?
LET'S BE HONEST, WHO DOES ALL OF
THE VOLUNTEERING?
I'LL GIVE YOU A HINT, YOU WON'T
FIND THEM AT A JAY-Z CONCERT OR
AT A NASCAR RACE.
IT'S MOSTLY UPPER MIDDLE-CLASS
WHITE WOMEN NAMED MELINDA AND
DOROTHY WHO HAVE TIME ON THEIR
HANDS SINCE HARRY AND LEO PASSED
AWAY LAST YEAR.
PICTURE JANET YELLEN BUT WITH
THE WOMEN'S HAIR CUT.
MEN ONLY VOLUNTEER WHEN THERE'S
A GUN TO THEIR HEAD, PROBABLY
BECAUSE THEY HELD A GUN TO
SOMEONE'S HEAD OR TAIL MEETING
ITS COMMUNITY SERVICE.
PICKING UP TRASH ALONG THE
HIGHWAY IS NO WAY TO SPEND FIVE
SATURDAYS.
I NEVER SHOULD HAVE MURDERED
THAT WEATHERMAN.
IF YOU TELL ME TO BRING AN
UMBRELLA AND IT DOESN'T RAIN,
THERE IS A PRICE TO BE PAID.
DIVERSITY QUOTAS AND UP HARMING
THOSE A POST HELP.
IT'S ADOPTING THE RHETORIC OF
EQUITY IN EXCHANGE FOR
CONFIDENCE.
IT'S ABOUT MAKING YOURSELF FEEL
BETTER INSTEAD OF MAKING THINGS
BETTER.
SCRATCHING A RASH INSTEAD OF
APPLYING APPOINTMENT.
I HOPE IT'S JUST A RASH.
AS "THE WALL STREET JOURNAL"
RIGHTS, CIVIC INSTITUTIONS HAVE
ALWAYS RELIED ON THE VOLUNTEER
WORK OF WOMEN WITH ENOUGH PUBLIC
SPIRIT WHO DONATE THEIR TIME AND
MONEY AND WE WILL MISS THEM WHEN
THEY'RE GONE.
WHO IS GOING TO REPLACE THESE
WOMEN, CATS?
HER IDEA OF VOLUNTEERING IS
WORKING AT A HOMELESS SHELTER TO
FIND A BETTER WEED CONNECTION.
WEED, IF WE'RE LUCKY.
DOCENTS ARE RACISTS, THEY ARE
PROBABLY WHITE SUPREMACISTS JUST
LIKE LARRY ELDER AND
CONDOLEEZZA RICE.
ACCORDING TO THE WOKE
CONSERVATIVES, BLACKS ARE
ACTUALLY WHITE SUPREMACISTS.
WHICH HAS TO CONFUSE THE HELL
OUT OF THE KKK, I GUESS WE WILL
FIND OUT WHEN JOE BIDEN GETS
INVITED TO THE NEXT FUNERAL.
DAVID DUKE SPENT HIS LIFE TRYING
TO BE THE FACE OF WHITE RACISM
AND CONDOLEEZZA RICE COMES ALONG
TO STEAL HIS THUNDER, WHY ARE
BLACKS STEALING THE JOBS OF
WHITE BIGOTS, MAYBE THIS COULD
BE PROGRESS.
IF OUR WHITE RACISTS ARE SO HARD
TO FIND THAT WE MUST RECRUIT
COLOR-BLIND BLACK LEADERS, HOW
AWESOME IS THAT?
WE KILLED RACISM JUST BY
CONFUSING IT TO DEATH.
I WONDER WHAT THE ANGRY BLACK
MALE THINKS?
♪ ♪
>> WHAT'S UP, FELLAS?
>> WE JUST HEARD THE NEWS, WE
ARE SO EXCITED YOU'RE GOING TO
BE TAKING OVER FOR US, WE GOT
YOU EVERYTHING YOU'RE GOING TO
NEED FOR THIS WHITE GUY STARTER
KITS.
OATMEAL, KHAKIS, JOURNEY'S
GREATEST HITS AND OF COURSE
COFFEE TICKETS.
HOCKEY TICKETS.
THIS IS FOR YOU, ENJOY THE
STARTER KIT, WHITEY.
AND CAN I BORROW YOUR STREET
CREDIT CARD?
♪ ♪
>> Greg: WHILE THE WOKE MEDIA
STOKE DIVISION, BLACK RAPPER
BRYSON GRAVES BOOTS ADELE WITH A
NUMBER ONE SONG ON iTUNES WITH
HIS ANTI-BIDEN SONG AND YOU HEAR
NOTHING ABOUT THIS BECAUSE THE
LEFT CAN'T DEAL WITH IT, IT'S A
CULTURAL SHIFT BUT THEY DON'T
LIKE IT.
A BLACK GUY BEATS A WHITE WOMAN
WITH A SONG ABOUT A TERRIBLE OLD
WHITE PRESIDENT, WHEN WILL HE BE
CALLED A WHITE SUPREMACIST FOR
THAT?
OVER AT THE FAKE NEWS SPORTS
SITE DEADSPIN, THEY CALLED KYLIE
IRVING AND DAVE CHAPELLE BLACK
PONDS ON A WHITE CHESS BOARD.
WHY?
BECAUSE THEY ARE BLACK AND SHARE
SIMILAR THOUGHTS AS WHITES.
INDIVIDUAL THOUGHT OF
TRANSCENDING IDENTITY GROUPS,
IT'S CRAZY.
DEADSPIN BELIEFS PEOPLE OF ONE
COLOR MUST THINK THE SAME WHICH
I THINK IS RACIST.
IDENTITY POLITICS IS NOW
SEGREGATING NOT JUST PEOPLE BUT
IDEAS, SKILLS, AND TALENTS WHICH
ALWAYS ENDS UP WITH BAD IDEAS,
LACK OF SKILL AND ZERO TALENTS.
IF YOU GO TO A MUSEUM YOU HAVE
TO IGNORE A WHITE DOCENT EVEN IF
THEY ARE GOOD AT IT IF YOU'RE
CONDOLEEZZA RICE, YOU BEST HOLD
AN OPINION THAT OTHER BLACKS
HAVE, ESPECIALLY FAMOUS BLACK
INTELLECTUALS LIKE JOY BEHAR.
SPEAKING FOR YOURSELF ISN'T
REALLY THINKING FOR YOURSELF IF
SOME D BAG AT DEADSPIN IT THINKS
SOUND WHITES.
SURE DAVE CHAPELLE WAS RIPPING
ON WHITES AND THAT WAS FINE BUT
ONCE HE MADE FUN OF TRANS, HE'S
NOT WHITE HIMSELF.
WE NEED A SCORECARD TO KEEP UP
WITH WHO IS RACIST AND WHO
ISN'T, MAYBE IT'S BEST TO SAY
EVERYTHING IS RACIST.
FINALLY SOMETHING WE CAN ALL
TAKE PART IN.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUESTS!
HE'S A PERFECT BLOKE TO PROVOKE
THE WOKE, COLUMBIA UNIVERSITY
PROFESSOR AND AUTHOR OF THE
BRAND-NEW BOOK, WOKE RACISM,
JOHN McWHORTER.
HE CAN DROP MORE BEATS THAN A
CLUMSY FARMER.
RAPPER, PRODUCER, RA.
HIM SHE PUTS RAZOR BLADES IN HER
OWN HALLOWEEN CANDY, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF.
HE IS SO TOUGH HE GOES BOBBING
FOR PINEAPPLES.
THE N.W.A. WORLD TELEVISION
CHAMPION, TYRUS!
WELCOME TO THE SHOW, NICE TO
MEET YOU.
>> IT'S GOOD TO MEET YOU TOO.
>> Greg: YOU HAVE GOOD TIMING
FOR THIS BOOK, WOKE RACISM.
>> THERE'S AN AWFUL LOT ABOUT
OUT THERE LATELY.
>> WHERE DOES THIS FIT?
AT THE IDEA OF DOCENTS.
>> HOW MANY PEOPLE HAVE GONE TO
THAT MUSEUM AND SAW THOSE WOMEN
AND SAID I WISH I WERE ONE OF
THEM.
THE IDEA IS YOU HAVE TO BATTLE
WHITE POWER, WHITE PEOPLE HAVE
ALL THE POWER YOU HAVE TO BATTLE
THAT.
IF YOU'RE NOT BATTLING THAT
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO GET INTO
HEAVEN AND YOU HAVE TO GET RID
OF THE WHITE DOCENTS,
CONDOLEEZZA RICE IS A WHITE
SUPREMACIST ALL OF IT MAKES
SENSE IF YOU UNDERSTAND THERE IS
A CHURCH OF BATTLING WHITE
SUPREMACY AND THAT BEING THE
ONLY THING YOU DO OTHER THAN MAY
BE TAKING SOME LESSONS ON THE
RECORDER NOW AND THEN, MAYBE
DOING SOME WATER COLORING, A
LITTLE BIT ELSE.
MAINLY WHAT YOU DO IS YOU ARE
FIGHTING THE WHITE MAN.
THAT'S THE RELIGION AND THAT'S
KIND OF WHAT MY BOOK IS ABOUT.
>> Greg: THERE'S A NEW ONE
EVERY WEEK.
HAVEN'T SEEN YOU IN YEARS.
>> I MOVED TO ANOTHER COUNTRY.
I MOVED AROUND WHEN TRUMP AND
HILLARY WERE GOING AFTER EACH
OTHER, YOU LEFT THE COUNTRY
BECAUSE OF TRUMP AND HILLARY, I
HAD KIDS OUT THERE.
I WASN'T AFRAID OF TRUMP AND
HILLARY.
>> Greg: YOU FOLLOWED A WOMAN.
>> A NICE SCHOOLTEACHER OUT
THERE.
>> Greg: WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF
THIS TREND?
>> ESPECIALLY WITH DAVE
CHAPELLE, THAT'S WHAT I SEE THE
MOST.
YOU GET DEADSPIN, RACIST WHITE
ORGANIZATION, OWNED BY RACIST
WHITE PEOPLE AND THEY GO HE
DOESN'T HAVE OUR OPINIONS SO
LET'S GET A BLACK WRITER TO
WRITE A COLUMN SO THEY WON'T SEE
OUR RACISM, HE'S SPEAKING FOR
US.
THERE'S ONE BLACK WRITER AND IF
YOU LOOK AT THE MAJORITY OF THE
BLACK COMMUNITY, THEY ALL HAVE
DAVE CHAPELLE'S BACK.
YOU LOOK AT THE REAL PEOPLE, NOT
JUST TWITTER PEOPLE.
DAVE CHAPELLE IS MY MAN, HE'S A
GENIUS, IS A LEGEND, HE'S ONE OF
THE GREATS, THEY ARE NOT TOO
OFFENDED BY DAVE CHAPELLE.
MOST OF THE WORLD GREW UP ON
COMEDY.
RED FOX INTO LENNY BRUCE AND ALL
OF THAT STUFF.
NOW IT'S TIME -- DAVE OFFENDED
US!
WE ARE NOT OFFENDED BY THAT.
>> Greg: EXCELLENT ANGRY BLACK
MALE, WELCOME TO THE CLUB.
>> YEAH.
>> Greg: I HAVE MONOGRAMMED
TOWELS.
>> I LOST MY MEMBERSHIP CARD, I
LOST IT.
PLEASE TAKE ME BACK, IT'S SCARY,
I DON'T LIKE MAYONNAISE AND
OATMEAL.
THEY MAKE GREAT POINTS, THE BEST
THING ABOUT DAVE CHAPELLE IS HE
IS IN THIS POSITION WHEN YOU
HAVE F YOU MONEY, YOU DON'T HAVE
TO PLAY THE GAME.
IF YOU DON'T ACT HE'S NOT
PLAYING THE GAME -- I GUESS THEY
GOT A SMALL VICTORY BECAUSE THEY
GOT THE DOCUMENTARY, NO ONE
WANTS TO PRODUCE IT OR WHATEVER
BUT THEN HE JUST -- I'M GLAD HE
DIDN'T DO THE APOLOGY, THE TWO
PAGE TWITTER APOLOGY BECAUSE
THAT'S WHEN THEY CUT YOUR HEAD
OFF.
I'M GLAD HE'S STANDING HIS
GROUND, BUT MORE PEOPLE ARE
STARTING TO LOOK LIKE ENOUGH OF
THIS, WE'VE HAD ENOUGH OF THIS.
IT DOESN'T HAVE TO DO WITH
RACISM, IT HAS TO DO WITH A
THIRST TO GET WERE SOMEONE ELSE
IS AT.
WE'VE SEEN SO MANY PEOPLE COMING
OUT THAT WANT TO TALK TO DAVE,
SO MANY PEOPLE WANT TO LECTURE
HIM.
LET'S DO THIS, HE WILL MEET WITH
YOU BUT THERE'S NO CAMERAS, NO
MEDIA, YOU CAN'T PROFIT FROM IT,
YOU MEET IN A DARK ROOM, YOU
SHAKE HANDS, YOU CAN'T TALK
ABOUT IT.
HOW MANY WOULD SHOW UP FOR THAT?
THAT'S NOT WHAT IT'S REALLY
ABOUT.
>> Greg: IF YOU GO AFTER A BIG
STAR AND YOU'RE JUST SOME WEIRD
TWITTER FREAK IT RAISES YOUR
PERSONA.
>> NOT ONLY THAT BUT HERE'S THE
DEAL, IT'S IRONIC YOU WANT TO
BUILD YOUR PLATFORM OFF THE BACK
OF ANOTHER BLACK MAN, WE'VE SEEN
THAT BEFORE.
YOU TALK WITH CHAPELLE, THEN
YOU'RE GOING TO GO ON THE VIEW,
THEN YOU'RE GOING TO GET A
REALITY SHOW, OF COURSE YOU ARE
OUTRAGED, THIS IS GOING TO BE A
LOT OF DOLLARS FOR YOU.
HE NEEDS TO MEET WITH US BECAUSE
OF ALREADY SPENT MONEY ON
PRODUCTION, THAT IS WHAT THIS IS
ABOUT.
>> Greg: YOU ARE REALLY THE
EXPERT HERE ON RACE.
YOU ALREADY HAVE THE BLACK DRESS
AND THE GLASSES AND YOU ARE A
WHITE WOMAN.
>> IF I HAVE KIDS, I WILL BE
GOING TO THE BAR WITH MY KIDS,
IF I DON'T I WILL BE DRINKING
MOUTHWASH, AT LEAST I HAVE A
PLAN.
IT'S NOT JUST A RACE COME OF
THIS WEEK NBC HAD A COLUMN, IS
KYRSTEN SINEMA BAD FOR BISEXUAL
PEOPLE BECAUSE SHE'S NOT FAR
LEFT.
WHICH IS WORSE IS MIXING THAT IF
YOU ARE ATTRACTED TO MEN AND
WOMEN YOU HAVE TO THINK THIS
CERTAIN WAY OR YOU WILL BE
PUBLICLY FEARED, OR THINKING FOR
HERSELF DESPITE SHE'S ATTRACTED
TO.
I'M NOT ABOUT GATEKEEPING WHAT
PEOPLE ARE ALLOWED TO BELIEVE
BASED ON GENDER, RACE, OR
SEXUALITY AND APPARENTLY THAT'S
A RIGHT-WING THING, I DON'T
UNDERSTAND.
>> WHAT'S HAPPENING AS WE SAW
THIS SEPARATION OF IDENTITY AND
RACE AS THE FIRST PART OF THIS
BUT WHAT THEY REALLY WANT NOW IS
THE SEPARATION OF IDEAS AND
TALENTS WHICH IS A DISASTER.
THE POINT OF A MELTING POT AS WE